[Music]  where's Joey  I haven't seen him in a while like a  couple months we're in like the middle  of nowhere and it's dark and we're  living by a fire we were waiting for  like five hours here and I'm like honey  like that's just bad host I thought this  is just a collab like I thought this was  like I thought a mission in the 70s was  just like a really cool YouTube video  idea I didn't realize it was like  full-on mission in the 70s here is this  the town this is really not the town the  letter from Joey said that there was a  town stuck in the 1970s that we had to  save now I love the 1970s I'm just here  to see you know like can we actually  time travel I think we've waited long  enough worried about you thank you so  tell us about this town yeah ha so I  need your help I really don't know much  about how we get there but I was given  this and we need to save this town  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]